- [Narrator] What we're
gonna do in this video
is try to break down the terminology
and a little bit of the
math of health insurance.
So the first question
that you might wonder is,
how much does an insurance plan cost?
In many cases, you might have an employer
who pays for all or
part of your insurance,
but in many cases, you have
to get your own insurance.
And so I'm going to
focus on the second case.
What I did is, I went to my
state's insurance exchange,
and I just looked up an indicative
plan for a family of four
that makes a combined $100,000 a year.
And this is just one of
the plans that I found.
I got rid of the company's name.
And what it has here
is the monthly premium.
So whenever people talk
about premiums in insurance,
they're talking about the
amount that you have to pay
to get the insurance.
So this saying that
you to have to pay $629.51 a month
in order to get this insurance.
You might also hear things
in terms of annual premiums
and you might guess how
to go from a monthly
to an annual premium.
If you multiply this number, $629.51,
times 12, you're going
to get an annual premium
of $7,554.12.
So this is how much
someone would have to pay,
likely you, in order
to get this insurance.
And what this is telling me on my exchange
is that this is actually after
a pretty big subsidy that I'm getting
from the federal and state government.
And most of this is happening
from the federal government,
but we can talk about
that in future videos.
The big picture here is,
if you wanna know how much a policy costs,
that's the premium.
This is how much per month,
and this is how much per year.
Now, the next thing that
you are very likely to see
when getting a policy is a
term called a deductible.
And one way to think
about a deductible is,
this is how much you will have to pay
out of your own pocket
until the insurance
really starts to kick in.
So here, we're looking
at actually two columns,
in network and out of network.
In network are doctors
and healthcare providers
that the insurance company
already has put in their network,
they already have some type
of an arrangement with,
while out of network, they
don't have an arrangement
with those parties.
So for this insurer, if you go in network,
you would have to spend
up to $6,300 on an individual
before the insurance
really starts to kick in.
So if you had to go and
get some type of a surgery
that costs $6,000,
even if you've been paying the premium,
you would have to pay
$6,000 on top of the premium
in order to get that surgery.
If that surgery, on the other
hand, for just one person,
let's say that surgery costs $10,300.
Well, in that situation,
you would have to pay the first 6,300,
so minus 6,300,
which means that the insurance company
would pay the remainder.
It would pay the remaining $4,000.
And in that year, if you
were to get other surgeries
for that individual, let's say it's you,
it would then be covered.
The insurance company
would pay above and beyond,
anything above and beyond the $6,300.
Now, you also have a deductible
for the entire family.
So they're not just totalling
what each individual is spending.
They're also totalling what
the whole family is spending.
So let's say I have four
people in my family,
and over the course of the year,
I've had to, for each of them,
I have spent 3,150.
I'm just using this as an example.
So each of them have not gotten
to their individual deductible yet.
But in total, my family of four,
3,150 times four, is $12,600.
After this point, even
though no individual
has maxed out their deductible yet,
now the insurance will also kick in.
Now when they talk
about a drug deductible,
this is a separate
deductible for the drugs.
So the one that I looked at before,
that could be general procedures
or certain types of care you might need,
while this right over here is specific
to what you might need for medications.
But it's the same idea.
If it's for any one individual,
the first $500 on medication in that year,
they're going to have
to pay out of pocket,
but then after that,
the insurance kicks in.
And then once again, $1,000
for the entire family.
Now, out-of-pocket maximum,
this says, no matter what,
no individual on an individual basis
should you have to put
out more than $7,800
for an individual, no matter what happens.
And no more than $15,600
for an entire family.
So this is real money
here, but it's saying that
you won't have to pay more than that
out of your actual pocket.
And then here, the maximum
cost per prescription,
this is the most that
you will ever have to pay
to get a prescription.
So even if there's some
type of exotic drug
that costs $1,000 per prescription,
the most that you would have to pay
is $500 per prescription for that.
Now that we've dissected
deductibles a good bit,
another term that you are
likely to see is copay.
Copay, one way to think about it is,
something that you pay every
time you go into that service.
So, for example, a primary care visit.
This says the first three visits
are a $65 copay before the deductible.
So this is saying, even
if you haven't used up
your $6,300 individual deductible,
your primary care visits are covered,
but every visit, you have to pay $65.
Now, the reason why they call it copay
is that you and the
insurance company are paying.
That visit might cost
the insurance company
another 150, 200, $250,
but you're paying $65 on every visit.
So the insurance company,
the insurance is kicking in
even before the deductible
has been reached.
Now specialists visits.
If you go to specialist doctors
like a cardiologist or a
rheumatologist or a dermatologist,
these copays only kick
in after the deductible.
So what that means is,
before you reach your deductible ceiling,
you're going to pay whatever
it costs out of pocket.
So if that specialist visit costs $500,
you're going to pay $500.
But once you've reached your deductible,
then every visit after that
is going to cost $95 is
what you would contribute,
and then the insurance
company would pay the rest.
Now, the last term I'm going
to introduce into this video
is that of coinsurance.
So what this is telling us,
right here they're telling
us how we are covered
for various drugs.
So, for example, if it's a generic drug,
these are things that are off patent,
then you pay $18 after you
have reached your deductible.
So no matter what the drug costs,
after you've reached your deductible,
every prescription, you pay $18.
Now these tier two drugs,
and I'm not gonna go
into detail about this,
but these are drugs that
tend to still be on patent,
and they tend to be more expensive.
What this coinsurance is telling us is,
you're going to pay
the drugs out of pocket
until you reach your deductible
for this insurance plan,
and then after you've
reached the deductible,
you're going to pay 40% of the cost.
So whenever someone
talks about coinsurance,
that means that you are splitting the cost
with the insurance company at that point,
and it's usually
specified as a percentage.
So the 40% is what you
would pay for that drug.
So let's say it's $100 a month.
You would pay 40% of that, so $40,
and you'd only get the 60% subsidy
from the insurance company
after your drug deductible
has been reached.
So I will leave you there.
I've already introduced
a lot of ideas to you,
but hopefully that will
already start to help you
dissect how insurance plans work.